tomorrow is election day in Alabama
voters have the option of choosing Roy
Moore the Republican serial child sex
assault alleged assault er who
previously said that the First Amendment
applies only to Christians who was
banned from a mall for being too creepy
around young girls that's one option the
other option is Democrat Doug Jones the
progressive with a clean record and the
right ideas on health care and education
and so many other issues sadly I don't
know which way it's going to go news of
a previous interview that Roy Moore did
was publicized over the weekend Roy
Moore once said that the United States
promotes a lot of bad things and that
maybe just maybe Russian President
Vladimir Putin is actually right it
seems like a video that would be part of
some Saturday Night Live parody about
Republicans but it's not it's actually
Republican Senate candidate Roy Moore
let's play the clip let's listen to it
you have said that Donald Trump was put
in the White House by God you know
everybody else thinks it's the Russians
I think this is providential hand of God
I think was by Providence that he was
placed there yes you were
I assume a supportive Ronald Reagan in
the 80s what do you think he would think
of the proximity between a US and
Russian president right now you know one
thing I've learned in politics it's not
to think for somebody else and assess
what Ronald Reagan would think I just I
just couldn't simply begin but he said
the Russia was the focus of evil in the
modern world you could say that very
well by America couldn't you do you
think well we promote a lot of bad
things you know like same-sex marriage
that's the very argument of a lot of Mir
Putin makes well then maybe Putin is
right maybe he's more kin to me than I
know I think that that's probably true I
think it's except I would say
pootin and Roy Moore are probably more
on the same page than we know and more
on the same page than Republican voters
are willing to accept I saw this
hilarious comment online something like
hey we knew that the USSR had a Georgia
in it but we didn't know it had an
Alabama in it as well that that seems to
speak to exactly what it is that's going
on here
another example of a so-called
conservative praising Vladimir Putin
criticizing the values of tolerance of
the United States we just keep trying to
treat gay people like the real human
beings and Roy Moore doesn't like it can
you imagine just for a second right if
one time just once President Barack
Obama said America's not doing that
great and maybe Putin is right it would
have been while I was going to say it
would have been conservatives calling
for his murder but there were already a
record number of conservatives issuing
death threats to President Obama more
than we've seen under American
presidents for a very very long time
how does for example taking a knee
during the national anthem to protest
racial injustice how is that on American
but Roy Moore criticizing the United
States and saying maybe Putin is right
acceptable in any way Roy Moore is a
really interesting test for Republicans
there are many Republicans who supported
Donald Trump because they saw him as the
guy that liberals hate and they wanted
to do exactly what it was that they saw
the left as disliking they did it and
it's been a train wreck for everyone not
just the left what will they do now and
even the other senator in Alabama a
Republican Senator Richard Shelby he
says he could not vote for Roy Moore so
that the people of Alabama shouldn't
vote for Roy Moore either more openly
homophobic accused of serial sexual
assault removed from positions of power
for violating the Constitution our
Republicans still going to vote for this
guy we will know sooner than later vote
tomorrow if you're in Alabama there is
still time to phonebank there is still
time to knock on doors this is
a major major test for the Republican
Party
the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as
one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad